Dance is very different
from other practices
in that it disappears
the instant that you see
a given movement, it’s gone.
And so it exists in the memory.
I came to New York
to study acting
and I was no good at that.
They said, “We don’t believe you.”
And my first dance class,
it took.
I didn’t know how limited
my physical resources were.
I didn’t have
a conventional dancer’s body.
If I had known, or recognized that
I might not have gone on.
But the pleasure of moving
was so great
that it overcame any reservations
I might have had.
That title of the piece
is “The Concept of Dust,
or How Do You Look When
There’s Nothing Left To Move?”
It was performed
at the Getty in LA a year ago.
And it was called “A Work in Progress”.
I didn’t feel it had coalesced
and there was still material
I was working on.
But I feel it’s ready to go now.